today's question comes from EJ in
Georgia he visits Dave Ramsey calm to
ask my name is EJ and I'm 17 year old
graduating senior of the class of 2020 I
want to attend a technical degree
program that is covered by a sponsoring
company which is basically all expenses
paid I'll receive an associate's degree
and gain employment with great pay and
benefits post-grad the issue is my
father refuses to sign to allow me to go
there he wants me to go to a four-year
college or a technical Academy
bankrolled by him personally I don't
want to go that route did the fact that
my dad is pretty controlling him paying
for my college is literally a ball and
chain I don't want what would you
suggest I do
mmm you worked in higher ed from most of
your career yeah three in higher it
can't tell how many students how their
parents would come in and they would say
my kid's gonna be a doctor my kids gonna
be a lawyer and you you have to turn
that conversation around where you look
at the kid said what do you want to be
when you grow up right and moms and dads
and they love their kids and they're
trying to love their kids the best way
they know how but they often do it by
trying to control every moment past the
time they live in their house so this is
a complicated one for the young man 17
so he doesn't have his own signatory
power yet if my son got a
all-expense-paid opportunity to go get
an associate's degree and gain
employment with great benefits and
that's what he wanted to do I'd
high-five him and I'd be excited for him
to go do that so I think what this
seventeen-year-old needs to do is to
talk to the the program and see if
they'll let him sign as a 17 year old
nursing after wait till he turns 18 I
think the broader question is to sit
down with his dad but again if you've
got a controlling dad had said no and he
knows enough to know as a 17 year old
that dad paying for college means dad's
gonna control my every move forever
that's a wise kid that that is asking
some questions I wasn't wise enough to
ask at 17 sounds like he's kind of got
his finger on the pulse of the way and
asked the question but dad wants it
seems fairly mature his mom didn't write
the email right right you know I'm just
thinking on the other side of it and I'm
just I I think what you're i think the
have you laid out is probably right I
don't disagree with you at all
when the Ramsay kids went to college
they had one choice if they wanted my
money they were going to go to this ah
there you go
that's Rand that could be considered
controlling but the stipulation is if
you want my money right and this young
man seems to know enough to know he does
I don't want his money
yeah and so if one of mine had said I
don't want your money I'm going my own
way then they could have done that but
I'm not going to fund unless you're
going to have a behavior pattern a set
of character traits a set of morality
I'm not going to put God's money and
make you a a well funded orgy attender
you know I'm just not gonna do it
I mean I'm not gonna make you a
well-funded beer pong player right right
right that's not my goal of sending you
over there as your dad who loves you and
a 17 year old that's a bit rebellious
who would call that controlling well I
was gonna say that's doesn't sound
rebellious in his language choice though
right sometimes when I was 17 everything
my dad asked me to do to take the trash
out or controlling me have my car back
so I can go to work while you control
[Laughter]
see that in this language choices no
it's mom that you always look at the way
people choose their words you sprinkled
in there I wonder if mom wrote this or
EJ stands for Elizabeth Jane but I'm
just throwing it in I'm not I'm it's
possible but I think if we take this on
face value which we need to do and give
the guy a break right then your your
answer is exactly right you're just
gonna wait oh you're 18 EJ it may be the
broader the broader conversation is and
where you're gonna live yeah and how you
gonna pay your car insurance and yeah
that all the bigger mom and dad fund
questions but I do think it's it's worth
a conversation at some point this is
what Anthony does so well is this idea
that a two-year associate's degree in
route to something else to your
associate's degree is somehow less than
worth less valued less and those can be
great opportunities to get into the
workforce technical
technical degree particularly if he's
going too hot into IT you know you can
get you can learn as much as you need to
learn in a two years program to get into
IT if you're gonna be a programmer right
you know that kind of a thing and so
we've heard lots of folks on our team
that do not have four years degrees and
information systems and they make they
are not starving no they are not no one
near them is starving
and so that's what's Ruby meta rail then
there you go you know it's just like wow
so but yeah that's it's an interesting
thing to think about the being the
17-year old and then I always think
about being the dad the controlling dad
of the 17 year old none of mine ever to
my face that I was controlling but I I
mean I was controlling but it's your
money in that sense and yeah it's my
money and you get you get my money
you get my rules right wherever it is
you know I don't we don't donate to
ministries that are going into debt for
instance and that's okay they can run
their thing I'm not telling not to run
their thing but I can't do that because
I don't borrow money so why would I give
you God's money as a charitable donation
if you're going to give it to the bank
that would be inconsistent with who Dave
Ramsey is and so I'm controlling right
you know but that's called just you know
living out your principles living out
your life your core values